ponsable d'un regroupement de soutien
aux familles nathalie d'amour a
rapidement constaté les impacts de la
pandémie sur les mers la femme prend
souvent sur elle beaucoup plus exemple
les charges familiales les charges qui
sont invisibles
le souci passe ou un report faire les
courses durant la première vague le
nombre d'heures consacrées aux enfants a
augmenté de 27 heures par semaine pour
les mères comparativement à 13 heures
pour les pères attention j'ai pas que
les conjoints son accent du tout je
constate aussi qu'ils sont de plus en
plus présent mais le petit déséquilibre
qui était et est encore là et ce constat
est encore plus en temps de crise nous
qu'on voit ses clients un recul au
niveau de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
le conseil d'intervention pour l'accès
des femmes au travail estime que la
moitié des licenciements ont touché les
femmes la baisse d'emplois se situe 7 %
comparativement à 4,6 pour les hommes
malgré la pénurie de main d'oeuvre un
plan d'action spécifiquement féminin
s'impose selon la ministre isabelle
charest mais on est allé vraiment ciblé
ou est ce que au cv qui avait des
impacts que où la pandémie allait causer
que l'impact chez les femmes off comme
si votre joli 23 millions de dollars
seront investis dans les ministères et
les organismes pour qu'ils augmentent le
soutien aux femmes dans leurs différents
programmes d'un colmatage en fait de
certaines brèches qui va faire en sorte
que justement on va pouvoir
plus spécifiquement à les rejoindre les
femmes d'autre argent est prévu pour
briser l'isolément des victimes de
violence conjugale et sexuelle
un enjeu qui a bouleversé le québec
cette semaine après un double féminicide
le gouvernement assure une mise en
oeuvre rapide pour toute la prochaine
année nous ce qu'on demande c'est
vraiment des financements structurants
récurrent pour avoir une certaine
stabilité avec ce plan d'action très
ciblé le gouvernement réitère son
message aux femmes il a besoin d'elle
pour la relance économique
ici véronique prince radio canada québec